the drug war is one of the most
successful jobs programs in the history
of the world
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissin
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is a
psychologist and neuroscientist who is
known particularly for his research into
drug abuse and other things related to
drugs dr carl hart a very warm welcome
to trigonometry thank you for having me
i'm happy to be here
it's a great pleasure to have you on the
show listen for you're well known in the
united states less so here in the uk so
tell everybody a little bit about who
are you how are you where you are what
has been your journey through life
yeah well as you point out i'm carl hart
uh i'm a researcher scientist professor
at columbia university uh my expertise
are in drugs
um that is studying drugs and people
trying to understand the effects of
drugs what they do what they don't do
i came to this area because i was
concerned about drugs
destroying my community in the 1980s
at least that's what we were told in the
1980s i was in the uk serving in the u.s
military and getting reports back from
home
where that
crack cocaine was uh destroying
communities like the one from which i
came
and so i i started to study psychology
and neuroscience and in order to have a
better understanding how drugs affect
the brain i figured that if i could uh
alter the way the that drugs uh like
cocaine affect the brain then i could
probably uh develop some treatments and
then if i developed some treatments then
i could
start to go a long way in solving the
problems that i thought were caused by
drugs in my community problems like
unemployment violence
a wide range of problems that were
attributed to drugs
some 30 years later um i have um come to
the conclusion that we all got
hoodwinked and i'm i'm trying to help
people to understand just how
and when you say hoodwinked i mean
you've set up the interview beautifully
because now everybody wants to hear what
you have to say
what is it that you think has happened
and why does the official narrative in
your opinion not represent the truth
well
if anybody ever watched a television
program a movie about drugs anything
about drugs uh drugs are always
scapegoated uh to be the problem
people who write movies don't have to
even develop a character if we say that
the person is a drug dealer the public
is already uh
primed to think that the drug dealer is
just a unidimensional bad person there
is no complexity to the person which is
nonsense there is complexity to every
human um and and so i thought drugs uh
were the problem in my community for
example um when in fact the problems are
the same things that have always been a
problem things like unemployment things
like poor education uh things like lack
of health care all of these issues have
always been the problems uh long before
drugs were ever in various communities
and long after drugs were in compute
communities these were always the
problem and they continue to be the
problem and we can talk about
some of my research findings some of the
evidence that bring me to that
conclusion
well let's talk about it so what does
bring you to that conclusion carl uh
let me give you one example one an
important example is this um
the vast majority of people who use
drugs are not addicted that is eighty
ninety percent of people who use drugs
never have a problem in fact they are
middle to upper class people who are
responsible they take care of their
families they pay their bills they pay
their taxes
in some cases like in our case in the
united states
some of those people even become
president of the united states you can
think about bill clinton you could think
about
george bush you can think about barack
obama all three of those guys reported
using drugs like marijuana and cocaine
when they were younger
just like many people around the globe
and they never become addicted the
people who become addicted and have
problems are
they have those problems because of not
drugs primarily because of these other
issues in their life like they may have
co-occurring psychiatric illnesses
co-occur in pain um problems they may
have
chronic uh unrealistic expectations
heaped upon them um they may have other
issues but oftentimes we have to look
via
beyond the drugs themselves
and look at the person's environment uh
the person of the personal situation
but drugs are
scapegoated so we don't have to look at
those more complex problems and that
those are the kind of things i'm trying
to share with people yeah that's it's an
interesting perspective but isn't the
problem like with alcohol which of
course is legal almost everywhere in the
world is that 90 of people can have a
glass of wine and then leave it there
but there is that small minority of
people who who do become addicted
whether that's genetic or whatever the
cause of that is and they are the ones
whether it's alcohol or other drugs who
are causing a lot of the problems in
society the violence the crimes the
burglaries the whatevers
and so yes most people don't get
addicted but the ones that do
who really have a terrible experience
and they inflict a lot of damage on the
rest of society
yeah you're making my point so if 90 of
the people who use alcohol don't have a
have a problem
then you can't blame alcohol i know you
just said maybe it's maybe it's genetics
and so forth
but it'd be nice if we had some evidence
to show that it's genetic which we don't
i know people who they they sometimes
say well we have disassociation but
association is not correlation
um and
like i said those problems become all
the things i talked about co-occurring
psychiatric illnesses chronic uh
unrealistic expectations uh sometimes
people were somebody in their community
they now lost gainful employment they
have no sort of prospects of
regaining their previous status all of
these uh issues are far more important
than the alcohol itself but we act as if
alcohol is the problem because it
doesn't require us to look any deeper
it's a any stupid person could say well
it's genetics uh without having any
information that it is genetics
and so what i'm trying to do is try i'm
trying to help people to look deeper so
the rest of us can continue to
enjoy our substances and then the rest
of us can maybe help solve what is the
problem with those people who are having
problems
so do you think the path to having a
better drug policy is decriminalization
and medicalization
of this problem
emphatically no
um so we have to explain
the difference between decriminalization
and drug legal regulation so
decriminalization simply says that
you're not going to arrest people for
personal use of the substance
selling of the substance remains illegal
that means that the people who are using
substances still have to interact with a
black market and there are problems with
the black market like you don't have
quality control your substance might be
tainted uh in the united states uh
between 1920 and 1933 we had alcohol
prohibition uh in effect uh what it was
kind of like a decriminalization such
that some people could good alcohol and
not have to worry about being arrested
but the quality controls weren't there
and so tens of thousands of americans
were maimed or killed because of tainted
alcohol because of having to interact
with the black market and so no i'm not
a proponent of decriminalization maybe
as an intermediary step on the way to
legal regulation but legal regulation
you can sell it legally and you have
just quality control such that people
can be sure of what they're getting
so
what do you think needs to be done
if you were in charge of the
government's drug policy
what laws and what regulations would you
implement or would you go for a
completely libertarian approach
well please let's not talk about a
political party or a political position
because that's i'm a scientist and yeah
and so when we start to talk about
libertarian conservatives what have you
and then people start to join camps like
they are on a [ __ ] football team just
saying
[Laughter]
this is this is much more complicated
than that uh yeah and
because you may have to dip into all of
these camps in order to come to some
solution that actually works so what i
think where i start is this most
countries around the world have
some sort of uh in their constitutions
uh something about people's right to
liberty people's right to freedom
and part of that right to liberty uh
deals with having the right to put in
your body what you choose as an adult
and so when i think about these
substances uh people should have the
right um
to put what they like in their bodies
particularly when substances are
actually make them feel better and
happier
increasing the likelihood that they will
treat other people better that's a good
thing and so my job then as a public
official would be how do we do this in a
way that
keeps people safe and healthier
and
make sure we don't have problems with
the substances and so i would legally
regulate the drugs that people are
seeking cocaine the opioids mdma
i will make sure that
our unit dose
that is the amount that is in a dose
that's in a package
is not enough to uh where someone can
kill themselves i would make sure that
the route of administration that is
available uh would not be for example
intravenous i would make sure that the
route could be in a form that one could
easily digest whether it's orally
whether it's putting underneath their
tongue in a way
that does not uh cause problems though
like uh intravenous use can cause some
problems and there is no reason for
intravenous use uh unless there is poor
quality of drug
and so i would i would use my knowledge
in pharmacology to make sure that uh
that the way that we make these drugs
available enhance the safety just like
we do when we give drugs in the
laboratory as part of my research
and so
we can use the knowledge that we already
have obtained
are you tired of using bulky old wallets
giving you a bulge where you don't want
it to be my old wallet was massive so it
brought all the ladies to the yard which
was a huge distraction and got in the
way of my esteemed work on trigonometry
bridge wallets have an incredible
solution for you this is mine sleek
stylish and with an industrial look to
it you can fit 12 cards with cash on the
back using a clip like this one or a
strap we've got one for the whole team
i've got one francis has one even our
producer anton has one but he's from
liverpool so he flogged his on the black
market the great thing about ridge is
that they give you a lifetime guarantee
which means if you want you can have
only one wallet for the rest of your
life ridge are so confident in the
quality of their product they will give
you 45 days to test drive their wallets
that means you can get the wallet use it
and if you don't like it you can return
it within 45 days because ridge are such
great guys they're going to give you 10
off and free worldwide shipping and
returns to take advantage of this
incredible offer go to ridge.com forward
slash trigger that's ridge.com forward
slash trigger and use our special code
which is of course trigger
[ __ ] may i ask you something just sort
of coming back to addiction and also
picking up on what you said about how
when people take drugs they feel good
and therefore they treat other people
well and by the way i'm playing devil's
advocate and sort of a good cop bad cop
going on because we've got to stress
test some of the things you're saying
but it's all said with the curiosity and
respect which i hope you know but when
you say when you say
the people feel better when they take
drugs and they treat other people better
i mean
i think that's true of marijuana
certainly my experience i don't know
that i think that that's true of cocaine
and alcohol for example right
well
you know we don't have to guess about
this you're talking to a person who has
given thousands of doses of cocaine to
people in the laboratory and carefully
studied their effects
i've given thousands of doses of
methamphetamine and other drugs to
people and carefully studied their
effects other people have given
thousands of doses of things like heroin
to people and carefully studied their
effects so no it's absolutely true the
date is dead the evidence is there is in
the scientific literature we don't have
to guess about this i mean
uh people take these psychoactive
substances because they make them feel
better or they alter their consciousness
in such a way
that is desirable for that person and so
that that's not uh
that's not a mystery i mean why else
would people take these substances
i'm sorry i do understand that we in our
media we have this nonsense where they
say oh the drug has a grip on that
person that's that's
that's tv that's drama that's not
reality no that's not what i'm saying
but i think what what i do genuinely
this isn't playing devil's out but what
i do genuinely disagree with is the idea
that people who take cocaine treat other
people better necessarily or the same
with alcohol like i don't think cocaine
makes people nicer people in my
experience
well
follow me here for a second please sure
if you feel better as a person whatever
you feel good
it increases the likelihood that you
treat other people better that's not
controversial and now now what you're
saying about cocaine please tell me what
you're saying you probably
will say
some
anecdote that you have about some awful
person who took cocaine and treated
someone poorly that's certainly possible
but in general when people take cocaine
they feel better just like any anyone
else who feel better you're more likely
to treat others better that's a just a
general statement that is uh i don't
know how one can argue with that
and carl what would you say to the
argument of that look right let's say
you legalize all these drugs you
therefore make them more prevalent and
once they become more prevalent more
people are likely to take them therefore
more people are likely to get addicted
yeah so uh as i pointed out earlier uh
when we think about drug addiction uh
the vast majority of people who take any
drug uh are not addicted so we can't
blame the drug for addiction so yeah if
we want to make sure that our society is
uh that people are not getting addicted
the way you you guard against that sort
of thing is that you make sure you have
a healthier society make sure that
people have
employment opportunities i mean real
employment opportunity not just these
sort of gig economies where they don't
have much support i mean real economic
opportunities you make sure you have
health care in your system you make sure
you have a healthier society that's the
thing that guards against um um
uh having a society with fewer numbers
of addiction but but let's not get it
twisted
any activity that's worth doing in this
human endeavor
um there is some risk attached to it
whether it's driving an automobile
whether it's flying in an airplane
whatever it is there is some risk
attached to it and so humans who are
looking for an activity with no risk
well i'm not the person to talk to
because that's not the world i want to
be in
the activities in which i engage
there is some risk
and then because
there's also
potential payoffs that's life and those
people who are looking for no risk
well that's a pipe dream and i don't
really deal in pipe dreams yeah it's a
good point carl i was gonna say do you
think part of the problem with with this
entire debate is that no one ever looks
at the substances objectively you've got
people on one extreme of the spectrum
going ah if you touch weed it's a
gateway drug and then by the end of the
day you're going to have a hairy needle
in your eyeball when you're going to be
mainlining it in and you've got people
on the other side who like no it's
absolutely fine it's a you know it's a
gateway the doors of perception william
blake etc etc the fact is we don't have
a sensible and rational discussion
absolutely you know my book is called
drug use for grown-ups right uh this is
a conversation for grown-ups and i want
to have a conversation with grown-ups so
we have those people on those extremes i
don't have time for that i'm now 55
years old i probably have fewer years
left than i've already been here and so
i'm trying to enjoy my life and i'm
trying to get at uh what's really
important and trying to leave a mark
where people who are suffering and
from those types of extremities they can
have something to read that i've written
and where they don't feel like they're
alone but yeah i don't i don't i try to
spend i try not to spend my time with
people who don't play by the rules of
evidence life is too short
and uh coming to your research uh which
is really the reason that we're really
interested to speak with you i guess the
basic question i would have for you is
why do people take drugs
uh it's a question it's like why do
people have sex i mean and beyond that
sort of religious sort of nonsense
reason that people give i mean if
sex feels good people like to alter
their consciousness so taking drugs
alters your consciousness helps the
people feel better in some cases helps
people be uh more empathetic or more
magnanimous a wide range of reasons is
why people take drugs in some cases
people take drugs out of curiosity
particularly young people but here i'm
talking about adults who kind of know
something about drugs i mean to connect
with a loved one
at a level a deeper level
um for they take drugs for a variety of
reasons
and and what about i i think johann
harry wrote uh talks about a lot about
the fact that drug addiction or drug use
is often a way to deal with trauma and
pain
yeah johan harry talks about trauma
mate
he talks about trauma yeah there are
people for example who
are experiencing trauma ptsd uh
post-traumatic stress syndrome um who
are who see things like uh mdma is
beneficial for that kind of trauma and
that is true
but
you know one of the things i tried to do
in my latest book drug use for grown-ups
is to get away from the pathological
frame so you know so like when when we
talk about drugs we oftentimes talk
about it from that pathological frame
like oh these people are suffering
that's why they're taking drugs or these
people are addicted that's a small
percentage of people the vast majority
of people who take drugs
are just like the vast majority of
people who take alcohol i mean like when
someone is at the pub
hanging out on a friday evening uh we
don't think oh yep that person's uh has
some trauma that's why they're at the
pub
no
uh we we think about them celebrating
with their mates and and having a good
time the same is true with most people
who take drugs
and and that's not a mystery it only
becomes a mystery because we've been so
dishonest about this conversation
and we have been dishonest about this
conversation it's such a good point and
we seem to have a really dishonest
attitude to psychedelics particularly
when you look at something like
mushrooms which i think was made illegal
in this country in 2005. i don't think a
single person has died from an overdose
of mushrooms why is it we don't have an
honest relationship with drugs in
general but particularly with
psychedelics
well i i think psychedelic
in general the psychedelics have
enjoyed a rehabilitation of their
reputation particularly here in the past
decade
in part because
the writers
our
reporters people in the media the
opinion makers
enjoy psychedelics like psilocybin like
lsd like ketamine a number of these
drugs writers
our opinion makers enjoy these drugs my
concern there is that they treat
psychedelics as if they are some special
class of drugs like they are somehow
um different
or the users of those drugs are somehow
seeking something different than the
users of say uh heroin or cocaine or
some other drug and so uh i don't think
of psychedelics as being special as it's
being elevated today in our society in
fact i think that's dangerous and then
that's the thing that's uh
one of the things i write about in a new
book psychedelics are not special but
i agree they certainly should be
available to people who are find them
helpful useful or enjoy them they
certainly should be available but my
concern is that we
we have started to pivot to say
this drug is okay but this drug is not
let me give you an example of a real
life example
pcp and ketamine are
chemical cousins they are nearly
identical in fact ketamine is made from
modifying the pcp structure
they exert similar effects but they have
wildly different reputations pcp
in the u.s
our police have told these nonsense
stories about how pcp
um helps to uh people to develop
superhuman strengths and so if someone's
on pcp they've said
you have to shoot them like 16 18 20
sometimes before you can subdue them
whereas ketamine has a reputation
it's actually approved in the united
states for treating depression it has a
more favorable reputation
now how this plays out in the united
states police oftentimes use pcp as an
excuse
to kill people um in fact last week
a chicago ex-police officer
recently got out of jail after serving
three years for shooting and killing a
17 year old kid 16 times he shot him
even when the kid was on the ground and
the public uh
virtually
said nothing in part because
the pcp was in the kids system and you
look at the video the kid was
running away from the police not coming
towards the police but the problem is is
the reputation of these drugs have these
wildly different sort of uh narratives
associated with them and so that's why
i'm a little concerned when we try to
act like uh ketamine or
or
psychedelics are somehow unique and when
in fact they're not
because but there's been quite a lot of
research coal in showing that and we had
uh dr david knotts who's heading up this
particular type of research telling us
about the wonderful effects that
psilocybin is having on treating
depression anxiety trauma so
are you very much in that camp that they
they can be used but they're not a
panacea is what you're arguing to treat
these types of conditions yeah i mean i
i published uh papers showing that
psilocybin can be used
to help treat something like cocaine
addiction i publish paper with mdma
showing how beneficial that drugs can be
under some condition uh mdma is
considered a psychedelic but really it's
an amphetamine it's not as it's a
psychedelic it's an amphetamine but it's
been um
i guess given honorary status in the
psychedelic camp because these folks
enjoy mdma all i'm saying is that if
we're going to talk about these drugs in
that way
then mention the fact that the
amphetamine to have been useful for all
of these sort of things like even
methamphetamine is fda approved fda
approved in the united states to treat
obesity to treat attention deficit
disorder so just bring all of these
drugs and don't don't act as if there's
just this special category that's my
concern
some people would say to that though
that some drugs are worse than others
and by the way what i would where i
certainly i think would agree is that
actually many of the drugs that we are
legally allowed to consume are far worse
than some of the drugs that are
currently illegal
but isn't it wouldn't it be true that
something like crack cocaine heroin
meth
are far worse and damaging to you and
alcohol by the way than something like
marijuana for example so shouldn't we
look at things differently on a
case-by-case basis
yeah i think we should i think that's a
good point but like the the assumption
that for example math is far more
damaging to you or heroin is far more
damaging
to you that's uh
we have to think about uh
what's the comparison uh and how we what
are we saying so when we think about
something like
uh heroin one of the things that we're
seeing is when we think about how
damaging it is we're thinking about
intravenous use for example for some
people
and
we don't need to use heroin
intravenously you can make heroin you
can use it you can have it be available
uh sublingually underneath the tongue
orally or into laser some other route
that
probably won't have as many problems
associated with it so it depends on the
route of administration then we think
about methamphetamine
is just like the amphetamine these drugs
have been used in the united states
forever for at least a hundred years now
and they've been
fined they're used in medicine and so
but they're taken orally in in those
cases and so
when we're talking about people making
illusive methamphetamine you smoking it
or shooting it then you might start to
see some problems but the problem
don't be aren't necessarily the drugs
themselves but it could be the
conditions under which the drug is taken
so when we think about taking drugs it's
important to talk about rotten
administration the environment that drug
use is occurring all of these things are
so important that is a really good point
and i actually i i'm glad you made it
because i think uh and this is again a
point you've made earlier already about
how we see things shown in the media and
movies etc when i was saying well heroin
and meth and whatever so so much more
dangerous really what i'm saying is the
my the image in my head of a meth addict
is worse than the image in my head of a
of a chain smoker right absolutely
absolutely that's that's that images has
been reinforced but with the media but
well if partly it's reinforced but
partly it's also as you point out it's a
product of the fact that these drugs are
criminalized right people wouldn't be
shooting up heroin intravenously if it
was illegal because it would be
available otherwise you wouldn't have as
many overdoses you wouldn't have people
ending up you know in this kind of
infectious situation where hiv is
getting passed on through needles etc
that's a really interesting point to
think about so
uh ki
i know this this question gets asked a
lot but other examples of countries that
have decriminalized all drugs or so not
decriminalized legalized old drugs as
you would uh where it's working out well
no um because of international
conventions uh countries have not um
legally regulated drugs and said what
countries do
they move to decriminalize drugs and and
they
have some sort of uh
or they have some de facto
decriminalization
where they're just not prosecuting or
arresting people for drugs um certainly
not in the levels that we are in the
united states
um
and so i don't think that you'll get
drug legal regulation
until you start to see more movement in
the united states case in point the
united states started to
various states on an individual level
started to legalize cannabis legally
regulate cannabis
now we have uh
at least two countries they have legally
regulated cannabis canada and uruguay um
and germany has said that they're
they're planning to legalize cannabis as
well
these kind of things are happening in
part because in the united states we
have about 20 states that have legally
regulated a cannabis uh for adult use
and so as the united states goes so goes
the world
and carl you talk a lot and you put you
wrote this open letter which i read
which i thought was fascinating you were
talking about the politics of
respectability particularly when it
comes to the politics of respectability
around drug laws would you be able to
talk about first of all explain to our
viewers and listeners what is the
politics of respectability and number
two how it affects drug laws
yeah so when we think about drug laws in
the united states uh especially uh
people think that drugs are banned
because of pharmacology because of the
sort of unique dangers that some
particular drug poses based on its
pharmacology and that's just simply not
true when you go back to uh drug
regulation in the united states the
first federal
regulations uh were in 1914
we
regulated or banned drugs like cocaine
and the opioid drugs
and we did so because of our fear of
black people taking cocaine and
there were media reports uh people
testifying before congress who were say
things like uh when black people smoke
cocaine or use cocaine um they became
impervious to 32 caliber bullets and
such that you if you unloaded your six
shooter into a black person's heart on
cocaine that person would not stop they
would continue to come at you they were
more murderous and they were better
marksmen these were the stories that we
told and these stories
were the primary reason that we banned
or regulated cocaine at a federal level
we told similar stories about
chinese people who had come over to the
united states and when it related to
opioids
and so and then with cannabis when we
banned cannabis we told stories about
mexican americans in that way
and so these are the reasons why that
these drugs are bad not because of
pharmacology now when we think about
politics of respectability
now we think like okay that's racism
classism and so forth that participated
and that's the reason that these drugs
are a ban
but our racism is not
limited to
the dominant white culture uh our racism
is it also occurs within those groups so
you have black people who were equally
uh sort of going at the cocaine or
saying the saying is nonsense about
cocaine repeating this nonsense and
trying to distance themselves from other
black people uh trying to show the
larger white uh population that we're
not like them we're better that's the
politics of respectability in fact they
even try to police the behavior of
members of their group in this way such
that they don't use cocaine so that's
what i mean when i say politics of
respectability policing uh the the
behavior of members of your group in the
way that you show the dominant culture
hey i'm uh deserving i'm like you i'm
not like those other bad black people
and so that's what i mean when i say
politics of respectability
and and that being the case do you think
we still
that still operates even now because you
talked about the crack
emphatically yes that's operation turn
on your television um you could think
about hip-hop music you could think
about a number of these sort of cultural
um
promoted promoters of information
and hip-hop disparages drugs and they
talk about
the horrors of crack they they they
participated in getting these awful laws
passed by telling these stories that had
no foundations in reality
um yeah this this happens all throughout
society just watch a movie
anything you can you'll see it but hang
on but carl but also rap celebrated the
use of smoking weed you know smoking
blunts etc etc so it's not so they
didn't just demonize one drug they also
celebrated another you know you look at
the chronic
i literally had a marijuana leaf on the
cover that's right
they celebrate the safe drug the easy
choice uh cannabis now is legal and for
most americans uh it's legal um
that's not edgy i i know it pretends to
be edgy but that's uh
it
it will celebrate cannabis on the one
hand and vilify everything else on the
other hand no foundations in reality
yeah that like you turn on your
television now the stories about
cannabis
are a lot more realistic than they were
say 20 years ago say 30 years ago a lot
more realistic uh 40 years ago the only
thing you saw in the us about cannabis
was cheech and chong and now we look at
that and we cringe because it was so
awful and so and it had little bases in
reality but people thought that was
reality and they laughed and they
tolerated that nonsense and so cannabis
is it's not edgy that's not that that's
that's not hard to do
uh when
you have been allowed to say okay this
is the way
that you can uh act up you can uh
express some sort of uh disagreement
with the general population i mean
that's the only way uh and and that's
the sort of sanctioned way that that's
not re that's
you get no cool points for that i mean
you get cool points for like following
the evidence
and
uh being the only person saying that or
because the evidence leads you to say
that
that's real cool the rest of that [ __ ]
no
i wish we lived in that world kyle where
following the evidence made you cool
i'm afraid we haven't lived in that
world for some time my friend i'm
telling you man we are this is where i'm
at you know
man that's that's exactly how i've
always lived my life and that's how i'm
living my life and so i don't know
anyone cooler than me
do you know what present company
you know what if i said that it'd sound
ridiculous and cringe whether when you
said that i went correct
but dude but let's talk about uh
marijuana weed whatever you want to call
it i don't think we're having an honest
discussion about it colin and i'll tell
you why because
to me we talk
about marijuana and
skunk is a completely different drug
isn't it skunk is far more powerful far
more potent far more likely to addict
you it's far more likely to create
mental health problems push back if i'm
talking rubbish because this is what
i've read i love the smile on his face
you're about to get destroyed with facts
in life okay come on destroy me
yeah no i just wanna i mean you're
absolutely right about like we have
these higher quality of cannabis so the
thc level the major active ingredient in
some like skunk is higher than
something like uh ditch wheat or some
nonsense that some people smoke so
you're absolutely right uh that we have
these different potencies now this
notion that uh it's more likely to cause
you to become addicted um
there's no evidence to support that i
know people say that in fact if you have
a higher
thc concentration cigarette you're more
likely to take uh fewer hits off of that
joint which is a better thing if you're
smoking because then you're not inhaling
as much uh
burning weeds down your throat which is
a good thing uh
and so and this notion about more likely
to cause you uh psychiatric problems now
if a novice smokes something like a
skunk the first time and they'd have
like no experience yeah that can cause
them to have more anxiety more paranoia
and that can cause them to have some
problems but the vast majority of people
they should just chill and relax and
the drug will float away from the
receptor and those effects will subside
uh subside even if it's hours later now
um like all of these leaps that people
are making into more addiction into more
psychiatric problems that's not i mean
long-term psychiatric problem that
hasn't been demonstrated and and that's
not necessarily
even a logical conclusion the most
expedient conclusion is that just think
about if you drink
if you have two drinks
you have a
a stiff drink with 151 rum and then you
have a drink with some
a lager you're going to drink those
differently if you don't drink those
differently you're going to have some
wildly different effect if you drink of
your
151 rum the same way you drink your
lager that's not a good thing and you
only need to do that one time and you
know that that's not a good thing and so
most people who
have just a
small degree of intelligence know that
and so
these people who are
predicting these horrible outcomes
are just taking uh divorcing what humans
really do they are acting as if humans
don't learn from these things but our
education can help people too
that's one of the things that has helped
when you know um the amount of tac in
your substance like in the us where we
have legal cannabis you can purchase um
cannabis cigarettes with varying degrees
of thc in it and if you are a novice you
know not to purchase the one with the
most amount of thc because that's stupid
hey kkk do you believe in spring
cleaning yes but only when my wife does
it in russia men who clean are executed
for not being real men which is correct
well for those men who are living in the
21st century manscaped has an incredible
offer for you manscaped are the global
leaders immense below the ways grooming
and have forever changed the grooming
game with their amazing performance
package 4.0
inside this care bundle you'll find the
lawn mower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker ear
and nose hair trimmer crop preserver
ball deodorant crop provider turner
performance boxer brief and a travel bag
to hold your goodies this elite trimmer
is designed to trim hair on loose skin
although your werewolves might look like
a couple of boris johnsons treat them
with respect and benefit from their
proprietary skin safe technology
complete your grooming game this spring
with the new refined cologne signature
scent by manscaped this stuff is legit
and will have you smelling like royalty
the good kind not prince andrew get 20
off and free shipping with the code
trigger20 at manscape.com that's 20 off
and free shipping with the code
trigger20 at manscape.com it's time to
throw out all your old hygiene habits
and upgrades your life
carl why is it that i'm having to ask
you these questions and my own media is
misinforming me i read about the effects
of skunk and i've read it in a variety
of different publications they're all
very reputable this is not some you know
bizarre site i go to on the internet why
is it that our own media and the sources
of information are not being honest with
us when it comes to this subject well
you hit on the the major reason that
we have this thing we call the drug war
these restrictions
because the drug war is one of the most
successful jobs programs in the history
of the world
now when we think about the media
you can write reports
articles on drugs you can write movies
you can write a number of stories about
drugs
and you can really increase the drama
and you don't have to have factual
information
well information that has been vetted
you don't have to have it you only need
to
have information that makes contact with
people's stereotypes about the drug and
so the quality of the control of the
information in the media is not vetted
as heavily as say
when you're talking about a politician's
position on some issue
it has to be heavily vetted the vetting
of drug information it doesn't uh it
just has to be in line with the current
sort of stereotype view of the drug and
that's the problem and and it gets it's
easier for the writer to get their uh
articles published um that's the real
concern so that so when we think about
the war on drugs we oftentimes think
about police benefiting prison officials
benefiting and we never talk about the
writers the lazy writers who benefit
from this nonsense i mean just just
watch any movie related to drugs and
you'll see what i'm saying
when drugs are involved we don't have to
to develop the character in the same way
we would have to develop other
characters uh and you have this
unidimensional sort of view of the drug
characters compared with other
characters um and
i was thinking about
like the sopranos i love watching the
sopranos shows like that on a show like
the sopranos the tony soprano is the mob
boss who kills people his nephew
christopher had a drug problem um and
they treated christopher
like he was a pariah like he was the
worst thing on the planet
now these people who are treating
christopher like this mind you now they
kill people on a regular basis but they
were looking at him as he was a horrible
person for taking heroin but not for
killing people
that's the kind of that's the kind of
[ __ ] that we bel we accept as viewers as
is as if that's okay
that's
remarkable
you know when you put it like that it is
remarkable and it leads me to the
question i was going to ask you which is
why are some drugs more equal than
others because this argument could also
apply to theoretically at least to
alcohol and tobacco but we don't seem to
demonize those and look i'm i'm a former
smoker i think tobacco is one of the
worst drugs ever it's [ __ ] useless
and it's bad for you at the same time if
you're gonna take a drug take something
that's gonna make you feel good at least
which tobacco really doesn't but we
allow those drugs we allow alcohol and
like you were you you served in in in
the uk as you mentioned so you would
have seen the drinking culture right if
you drink
50 pints on a saturday night you're a
legend absolutely absolutely right
and if and if you're doing something
that's illegal then then you're a
criminal and you're the worst thing in
the world
why are some drugs allowed and some are
not and by the way why are the shitty
ones allowed and some of the better ones
not well
you just said what i say damn it every
friday night when my wife and i are
seeking some substances like why are
they why is alcohol allowed and not mdma
that's a great question but um it's
simple
in our capitalistic societies those
drugs have a foothold and people are
making a lot of money off of them in the
united states for example
when we were making drug legislation
every major drug legislation
that regulates drug hads in it
alcohol and tobacco are exempt and they
they get exemptions um in large part
because they had well-established
lobbies and their lobbies ensured that
their drugs were exempt
even when we had discovered that
the tobacco companies for example was
misleading the public about the safety
of their product
they by that time their lobbies had so
much money they could still withstand um
this truth coming out so it was it's
really about the money
and the influence that those industries
have in our society so it's entrenched
interest but a question i suppose i
would ask is why if you were a massive
alcohol company surely the thing that
would make the most sense is you
encourage the legalization of other
drugs and then get into that business
yourself because you've already got the
infrastructure to distribute it why why
aren't they lobbying for that car
well because they uh are uh going with
public opinion just like politicians and
what they're trying what they try to do
uh is to say that
our substance is not like those other
drugs in fact we're not really a drug i
mean that's these are they trying to
convince the public that they're not re
even a drug which is nonsense and so
that's where their
they have put their efforts like well
and tobacco goes a step further and say
we are an agricultural product you know
all of these drugs all of these drugs
we're talking about are agricultural
products but you don't hear uh folks
using that kind of uh language because
but the tobacco companies have years of
experience with this
why do we look at
people who take drugs uh people who sell
drugs
but mainly people who take drugs and in
fact drug taking as a whole
as a moral issue
we tend to look at people who take drugs
as immoral why do we do that
we have convinced the public the regular
common person in in the public that
um uh
your uh
value
is attached to
your ability to abstain
from
these pleasures um this sort of
protestant work ethic uh it's the we are
uh you uh
you resist you abstain um and and and
you work
hard um and and you don't have these
unearned pleasures unearned pleasures uh
and and so we've convinced the common
person of this nonsense uh and so the
common person can say
well at least i don't use drugs you know
i may not have may not have the job that
i want i may be a horrible person i
treat my
significant other poorly but i don't use
drugs i mean you can see this one of the
things that used to make me laugh in the
1980s is that
some hip-hop artists they they do these
public service announcements about
staying off drugs back in the 80s i was
a dj
and i did some shows with run dmc and we
got high together uh at a show like was
smoking some weeds some
little lightweight stuff and then like a
few weeks later i see run dmc in a
public service announcement saying
something like what's up we run dmc and
i raps about something which there's no
doubt when it comes to drugs just say no
we've teamed up with the drug
enforcement administration and millions
of people who won't fool with drugs not
now not ever who wants to be involved
with something that can rob you of your
job your future your self-respect your
family even your life nobody does that's
why where drugs are concerned the only
thing to do is just say no
stay off drugs you know don't do drugs
and um meanwhile some of these folks are
doing horrible things but
you're excused if you say stay off drugs
and so drugs have been
that sort of activity that people can
use and say at least i don't do drugs i
may be a horrible person but i don't do
drugs
what do you think about the conspiracy
theorist position cole which i've
migrated to more and more over the
pandemic just with everything yeah just
because you've been smoking a lot of
weed
correct um
but what do you think of the conspiracy
theorist position that the reason that
they've banned psychedelics the reason
that they've banned all of these drugs
is because they they they get you to see
the world in a different way and if you
see the world in a different way then
you start questioning things and once
you start questioning things you stop
being you know a good worker drone as it
were
well
you know when we figure out how to make
money off of these drugs and
in a way that we're figuring out how to
make money off cannabis i think that um
some of them will become more available
particularly the psychedelics
i think the almighty pound or dollar
is what really drives these things i
mean right now it's just so much money
in restricting drugs um and that's the
main driver uh it's just that
everybody's making money off of the
current legal scheme um and so when we
discover how to make even more money off
of legally regulating it i think it'll
be legally regulated so i i try to just
follow the money because
frankly i don't think they're smart
enough to think through this kind of
thing about oh you see the world
differently i i
i think many of these people actually
believe that you take a drug like uh
heroin mdma cocaine that you have some
problems i
i don't think they're smart enough
frankly there you go france i think what
dr hart is saying is stay off the weed
mate you're not smoking too much uh but
uh carl before we wrap up the show i i
one of the things we haven't really
touched on um you were talking about
what people call the crack epidemic and
basically i think what one of the one of
the things you're talking about there is
the impact of the criminalization of
drugs on communities and
the the way i feel about this and the
reason we talk to people like you is
i remember reading a lot about what's
happening in mexico
and this is a country to us on the far
side of the world
uh you know to i don't know many mexican
people it's not a country to which i've
been i don't feel a connection but when
i read about tens of thousands of people
who are being butchered every year when
i read about some of the horrific
atrocities that are happening that's
when i start to go well look i
appreciate that i think legalizing drugs
will have certain negative trade-offs
but at least it will take
away these billions of dollars that are
currently going to some of the worst
human beings in the world only because
there's a profit to be made and that
profit is only able to be made because
these drugs are illegal
yeah i mean when we think about horrible
people in the world you should probably
look at some of the people who are
leading our countries yours mine other
countries um
i think those people are equally
horrible but the problem is is that they
have these media machines that don't
show them in the negative light that we
see
so-called drug cartel leaders are shown
and so i think we should be careful
about well hold on sir what do you mean
so-called drug are you saying there's no
drug cartels no no no
there are drug cartels but the ones who
we prop up as the evil folks i mean not
i'm not defending now
this is more an indictment of people
like your leader boris johnson and biden
no argument
what i'm saying is that these people are
equally horrible in terms of having
people killed and not so that's what i'm
saying
now uh when we think about
legalizing drugs
so that uh you take away the black
market yeah you certainly will take away
uh that black market but uh
it's
frankly naive to think that we're going
to take away black markets in general
because as long as
there are people who are suffering and
they are not allowed to participate in
the sort of mainstream economy people
will seek alternatives i think about in
places like brazil i spent a lot of time
in brazil
there are a lot of people who've been
shut out of the mainstream economy and
some of those people are in drug
trafficking but drug trafficking is not
only what they do
these organizations do a wide range of
things and so when we focus our
attention only on the drugs or the trade
again we're missing the mark and we are
following that easy story it's a lot
more complicated than that
so you don't think if we if we legalized
you know the drugs cocaine etc etc
would it in your opinion would it
fundamentally change the black markets
in mexico or do you think these people
will then just go work in other black
markets because they've been ostracized
from society they're already in other
black markets i mean this notion like
there's a notion that they are just drug
traffickers that's so that's nonsense i
mean just like the tobacco companies
when we really started to put the
pressure on the tobacco companies in the
1950s and 60s
the thing they did was that they
diversified your cereals your sugars all
of these sort of things they're owned by
the tobacco companies they just
diversified they're in these other sort
of markets any smart business
has diversified and that's what these
folks have done and so when we focus on
like just the drug markets
that's that's not very smart
and cold what do you think the future
holds now for drugs do you think it's
going to be a steady case of you know
legalization and we're going to have a
far more sensible approach to it or do
you think we're going to we're going to
carry on with this
quite infantile way of discussing a very
serious subject
i think we're going to continue with our
infancy
with some drugs most of the drugs of
cannabis will be moved out
and we
will continue to see
growing legal regulation around the
world as governments and think that they
can make money off of that one but these
other drugs um i don't see the stupidity
stopping in any way which is unfortunate
that means that a lot of people are
gonna unnecessarily die
that's not that's not a good note to end
them so let me before we ask you a
couple of questions from our supporters
on locals uh let me ask you a final
question which is always the same what
is the one thing that we're not talking
about as a society that we really should
be
um so in my latest book uh drug use for
growing up chasing liberty in the land
of fear
the thing i i started out to write a
book
a love story about love and how uh drugs
um have these
tremendous beneficial effects and how
it enhanced the drugs can enhance your
sort of um
understanding empathy of other people
and
it was a book about love
and
uh you can never talk about love when
you're talking about drugs because
everybody wants to talk about
addiction and these problems that are a
minority of drug effects uh it's like
saying hey let's talk about i want to
talk about cars i want to you know i'm a
car enthusiast and then the audience
only wants to talk about car crashes and
so
um
we're not talking about love we're not
talking about
the empathy and the sort of
generosity that occurs uh when people
are in these states um and i think
that's what we should be talking about
more and i i try to do that but
invariably i get i have to um go i have
well i'm a university professor but i'm
always asked to teach elementary
students uh school primary school
students and it's maddening because i
want to teach university at the
university level carl
it's a very good point i don't know if
you know this but you know uh we had a
massive problem with hooliganism
football hooliganism or soccer
hooliganism in the 1980s in this country
and there's yeah and there was lots of
you know legislation brought in and we
prosecuted people
and it kind of ebbed away but actually a
lot of people have said that the reason
that the football hooliganism kind of
died out was because all the football
hooligans got into ecstasy at the time
of the ecstasy boom in the late 80s
early 90s so actually all the all the
hooligans were off their face on in a
rave
well i don't know about that you know
you know the acute effects of mdma
they're great um
it helps you to uh be more understanding
of other people's perspective it helps
you to kind of look outside of yourself
that's a great thing and sometimes you
know you have this ather globe like
these effects can last several days
later which is a lovely thing
uh and even months later um
so uh but i don't have any evidence
about the football hooligans um but if
it actually happened and they got into
mdma used i i hope they're safe and and
and more power to them all right well
our producer is an angry football fan so
maybe we'll know how to deal with them
now yeah we'll put it in his teeth yeah
there may be no scientific evidence
we're going to give it a shot anyway uh
dr carl hart thank you so much for
coming on i recommend people check out
your book where is there somewhere for
people to follow you online to keep in
touch with your work
yeah dr i'm on twitter
carl hart um
i'm everywhere on twitter i mean i i
don't um
do twitter every day because um
yeah it's too much hate on twitter so i
i have to step back and i'm i'm trying
to be i'm trying to uh love not hate
well we'll we'll do a couple of quick
questions for locals but in the meantime
thank you so much for joining us and
thank you guys for watching and
listening we'll see you very soon with
another brilliant episode like this one
or raw show all of them go out 7 7pm uk
time and for those of you who like your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
dr hart what good exactly do you think
you're doing with your drug advocacy
[Laughter]
um
wow